le département vous présente terre de
trail
[Musique]
à
presque arrivé c'est ce que nos ancêtres
se disait à la grande chaloupe afrique
chine ou encore l'inde tous passés par
cette quarantaine ici clovis le sait le
temps s'arrête alors à la lex sed et
apple a beaucoup à voir ou d'autres
arrivées rappelle clovis et je
suis guide patrimoine à l'office du
tourisme de l'ouest où là la grande
chaloupe frais dans un site exceptionnel
au niveau patrimoine à l'aube à times
square et voilà bonjour comment il est
efficace
[Musique]
ce sont des portraits de travail est
engagé
donc tu vois on va représenter toutes
les origines indien cafres donc
africains chinois
si nous toutes les mélanger il faut que
ce soit un monument on va dire qui
représente tout le monde
notre diversité nous traînions y ajouter
un monument voilà et pas seulement un
monument qui représente kilos représente
une communauté
en parlant de l'africain mon arrière
grand père c'est du canada est passé par
lazard et je pense par le lazaret avant
de la rédac
oui effectivement c'est un lazaret qui a
été mis en service avant le lazaret de
la grande chaloupe et donc il y avait un
compte de marques à terme l'époque
il croit commande un endroit intéressant
il ya du patrimoine les lieux la série à
et de 0,2 malheureusement les grandes
routes la route du littoral notamment la
fait que nous passent à côté d'un dieu
qui il était incontournable dans notre
histoire de la réunion à peu près tout
les toutes les périodes la possession
depuis la position du roi comme qui
dirait lot jusqu'à en passant bain avec
les premiers propriétaires que la belle
terrasse atteinte et sheila des motards
donc toute la dynastie des techer
dynastie dont on a toujours des
histoires il raconté et cette petite
pause là et puis on m'a moussan par le
temps les suspendus d allah
c'est un lieu charismatique quand même
c'est un lieu d'échangés par que
d'histoires mais changer de tradition
chargé de culture changer tout ça le
lazaret quasiment tous les réunionnais
nana un concept qui est passé parlent
d'un sas sanitaire
donc si on a un hommage à faire notre
ancêtre pour moi une fois venir ici
connaître un peu l'histoire faire ce
lieu là un lieu de commémoration
il faut que ce soit un monument que vous
présente tout le monde
moot diversité pas satisfait un peu
l'énergie un peu 707 qui vais rapporter
à ses 20 derniers kilomètres jusqu'à la
rue doute là bas pas un petit coup
demande d'essence est là la passe t elle
a un petit peu l'énergie le courage
coupe le globule zaho même la première
précis bien précis le bio wen a bien
raison que dix mois mais ça va la
redoute à temps à moi allez merci pour
la visite à l'est vaudois a trop
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
le département vous a présenté terre de
trail